it's another day of homeschool at the Hollies
and today we're starting with speech therapy
today we tried something new and went live during our math lessons
and we had a blast I really love sharing our homeschool days
and I am so passionate about helping
and teaching other parents how to homeschool too
you get little snippets of that here and there and these voice overs
but going live was just a whole another level
it was like giving you a front seat into our classroom
basically you got to see a real
unedited school which was so cool
is to encourage other parents who are either new to homeschooling
or on the fence about homeschooling
that you can do it too
it also give you all a chance to ask questions about what I'm teaching
why I'm teaching different teaching methods
different curriculums all of the things
and those are the things I absolutely love having conversations about
I will say it was a bit of a distraction
and kind of hard to do both at the same time
so I'm not gonna do it all the time
but I would love to do this more often
if it's something that you would find beneficial
so if there's like
a specific topic or subject that you need help teaching
and kind of want me to teach you how I would teach it
let me know in the comments
maybe we'll start like a TikTok live trading
where I teach you how to teach your own kids
so we can all be homeschooling together
the requirements would be a cozy blanket
coffee and lots of snack
now that sounds like a teacher trading I could get into